hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update according to creative
director Neil druckmann the last of us
on ps4 was actually limited more by disk
space than by system capabilities the
playstation 4 uses a blu-ray disc for
physical game delivery and apparently
naughty dog was starting to feel limited
by the format storage capabilities in an
interview with edge magazine druckmann
said it's interesting that now instead
of a technical bottleneck the bottleneck
is can we fit all this on the disc the
last of us was released less than a year
ago but with the new consoles
capabilities Naughty Dog co-president
Evan Wells explains that quote the
graphics fidelity has been turned up to
11 we've got 1080p we're pushing the
draw distances further we're creating
higher resolution character models that
are lighting better shadows no mention
on why they aren't opting for a solution
that's been around since the floppy disk
just using more disks phantasmagoria
seven cds you know what i'm talking
about for more The Last of Us and
PlayStation news be sure to stay tuned
to gamespot com